all right my next guest huge star blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah
big-time blah blah movies television
he's done it all like bogie and Bacall
yeah ladies and gentlemen a good friend
and neighbor Adam Sandler Adam how you
doing what are you only good neighbors
everyone else on the block is so scared
of you I know what why are they scared
of me why do people in this neighborhood
afraid of me you do that you do that
weird freckled naked run every morning
at that foot like do it come and you
scream it on the cone man over and over
it's crazy I like to show people what I
got I like to get outside you get rid of
that you get rid of it right away every
morning like here it is here it is let's
move on next not speculate I'm gonna let
everyone see what I'm packing how's the
quarantine going for you Adam ah just
like everybody else Tony I'm here I'm
the kid like usually like the run away
to the hoe daddy's losing it again let's
go out let's go shopping
yeah now they're kind of now they're
really getting to know me and they're
really not one of them is happy being
here there's you know I've been yelling
more than I used to now you do you do
you are a bit of a Yeller I've been
around you when you yell yeah your your
guy likes to yell and say kids kids what
are we doing we gotta go we gotta go
that's you in normal circumstances what
are you doing now in quarantine well
usually it's been a known fact that I
scream all the time but it goes away
reasonably quick I have to say my
screaming has extended like this a new
version of me the kids are like okay
it'll go away and then they're like
looking at each other like oh he's still
going and I'm going I have just very
tense about everything and I'm just like
don't you touch that
that's it I didn't clean that yet and
mommy did you know I'm just I'm worried
about everything clean to the house and
you're wiping everything down I wipe a
lot of stuff down then when I pick it up
pick up things to eat I'm like oh yeah
did I already touch that are my hands
dirty so I clean my hands again and you
how about you buddy you doing anything
are you just kind of just sitting there
allowing everyone else to do it for you
in your home you still have a staff in
your home yeah I have a hundred and
seventy people here you can't do that at
this time really no one told me now I'm
told me a specific order by the governor
of California you can't have ten or more
in the house don't eat off let all those
guys I let half my people go and it's
now a hundred and seventy people they
dress me they wipe me down with alcohol
they thought they'd feed me soup they do
my they put my wig on everything is
taken care of they paint the freckles on
are you getting outside the house you do
ever go outside yes I had a terrible
situation happen now they're not
terrible but can I tell you going to use
it yeah you can tell me no one's gonna
see this that's all so I'm on I take the
kids out in the nude or we got a dog
basil begging expecting everyone else to
be keeping their distance right you can
go outside as long as you're far away
from other people
stay away man the six feet thing I'm
making about 30 feet like just let's
let's get away stay away from other
people children let's if we got it we
don't want to give it if they got it we
don't want to get it anyways I got the
dog and I noticed some people don't have
the dogs on the leash and I know I see
if dogs come into my dog and then I'm
gonna have to like separate with all
this is gonna be a fight the guys gonna
come over well I'm gonna have to be
close to this guy breaking up a fight so
I start screaming hey put the dog on a
leash put your daughter so then this
nice lady is walking towards us me too
wiping the kids and I say can you put
your dog on a leash she goes what
hey she does I said can you put your dog
on a leash because what's this and she
was on the on the phone or something
she's gonna hear me calm he starts
getting closer to me I go no no can you
put your dog on a leash she goes I live
right there I know I know I know just
the dog I don't want the dog she goes
you don't always have your dog leash I
know well I I know but that Corona thing
she just won and she starts coming at me
and I'm a crazy person she's getting
near my family said I started going
like a crater she goes you are a jerk
and she starts screaming at me that I
was a very very corona tense moment for
us and I yeah but you know let me tell
people something that woman's name was
Barbara Streisand I didn't mean to be
abrasive or loud I meant to just say get
the dog on a leash you shouldn't be
having dogs touch each other and getting
close to each other that's it yeah all
right that's all and I think you were
being reasonable in that situation I
think we're all a little tense and I
think you handled yourself well and I
hope barbara streisand gets it together
she just by the way I woke up this
morning with his long message people
people who need and I was like oh she
try to make up see it turns out nice hey
let me ask you a question this is what's
been bugging me I'm terrible at tech my
son has been making fun of me for years
I can never figure stuff out and now
that we're all on our own we got to
figure this stuff out are you good at
tech now absolutely you know I can't do
anything this is like I've been
facetiming my my buddy Loughran who sues
helps me out literally everything I
didn't know how to turn on my so many
things in my house I don't know how to
well whatever it's humiliating oh I can
do the UH if the electricity goes down I
can find the circuit and flip it on and
off and when it works I'm just like I
handle that one that's that that's what
I'm most excited it's the smallest thing
and you feel like MacGyver right yeah
change the battery on my mouse the other
day or on my computer thing and I open
it up put a couple of doublea's in there
and it worked
that is not the voice of a tech guy but
you think my wife knows a lot more in
the house than I do my wife always knows
everything and
how everything works she's a good cook
she everything is I mean I'm always
saying stuff like where do they put the
sink and she said Cody you an idiot it's
right there in front of you and I mean
like how am I supposed to know I'm a
genius you know I'm the creator I can't
know where the sink is it's ridiculous
someone told me that you're wearing
t-shirts that you get from restaurants I
don't even know what that means what
does that mean when I go to a restaurant
a lot of times when I'm leaving they say
hey Adam you want a t-shirt and I say
yeah sure you know and I say say what
sighs and I say double X and they go no
and I go well yeah and then they go
really shown that it's not that loose
and it's a little loose but you Adam I
say I know but uh in a minute we have
stopped you for a second you say that
when you go to restaurants this is long
before the coronavirus but just as a
matter of habit and a matter of course
they give you free t-shirts at the very
end of the meal a because I'm nice I'm
nice to people I and we live in the same
neighborhood
I've never gotten a t-shirt they don't
give me t-shirts well that's an extra
extra long on you man that doesn't make
sense you can't wear t-shirts are you
extra long waste ahead or no no I'm
sorry wrong in the leg you got long legs
what are they yeah oh they're crazy legs
I got like 39 inch legs you know hey I
have super long legs and then I have a
tiny torso I have the chest of a of an
eight-year-old girl yeah massive long
legs yeah and I got it's just I'm so I'm
disproportionate you know you like when
you're laying in bed are your legs
kicking around you don't even know it
you young oh you you feel your legs
right yeah I can feel my legs Adam yes I
can feel my legs
yeah yes sometimes I'm fast asleep but
my legs get up early and they're like
hey he's still asleep hey right he's
still asleep yeah left let's get cooking
and then they start doing all kinds of
stuff yeah sometimes I wake up and I'm
just running 18 miles an hour down the
street yeah I'm in a Samba class it's
craziness yeah I like the mustache by
the way it looks like you're going to be
making pornography and Quarantine
[Laughter]
everybody else has mentioned that
there's a rise in watching for no
horizon sexual activity oh is that true
being very experimental with me oh
you're trying new stuff with the wife
yeah she she showed me this new thing
the other night that was bananas and you
have to try this especially with your
crazy legs you hold yourself up you like
his leg beneath you yes you do the boobs
wait I'm just like what is happening
wait so I've seized and I do the moves
so you get basically almost a push-up
position or a plank as you like and then
it's a lot of hipping and chipping so
this is going to require a lot of core
strength on my part yeah you got to
prepare for this prepare like two three
months get your body ready and then 20
second plank you can do this yeah well
my my wife thinks that we should stay
six feet apart you've been saying that
since Obama's first term joke there is
it's not related to coronavirus right
kind of a loveless marriage
did you ever huh sometimes you go up in
tone for no reason I don't know what you
hang on Sonny what do you got baby my
son is bringing me the coffee you want
to see how to code it tell Sonny that
uncle Coney says hi honey how are you
I'm gonna you bored are you having fun
um tell Cody how much daddy's been
screaming lately yeah I told him about
that with the dog I wasn't screaming at
her I was trying to get my point across
she called me Josie it's a true story
that's a true story so he really did
scream at a woman who was I was trying
to get her attention she had something
arere I think your father was in the
right we have to maintain social
distancing and I think your father did
the right thing sunny she was very nice
and I told her I'm trying to tell her
I'm sorry hey tell kony what I hey Conan
when we passed your house swear to god
I'm telling you the truth whatever we
bet your house walking to do what daddy
does also the other night we were
practicing to stay on the flop and then
get the hell out of you ready you want
to do the day already there we go go
okay thank you thanks for that coffee
say goodbye honey yeah bye by the way
Tony if you want what you know well
let's get a shout out to that coffee
company who makes it I don't know but it
tastes like Billy Billy that's good
coffee
let's get the word out up man you know
we got to get people employed you know
thank you to all the businesses staying
open and the food and that people being
so cool and serving us food in grocery
stores and restaurants that are staying
open just for us and then drop dropping
an offer or let you know be a nice time
people bringing it out there you are
yeah I can't believe I thank you so much
I really it's an amazing thing you do
Mike
you I'm thinking about a lot of these
small businesses we know a lot of these
people because we see them all the time
at different restaurants waiters that
help us out you wonder how are they
getting along and so we've got to be
figuring that out as we go and what to
take care of each other yeah absolutely
and I hope this gets done real soon I
hope so man it's it's heartbreaking
heartbreaking many people of Italy I
exploited speak Thai you know I did a
movie in Italy and would with Jennifer
Aniston and we got friendly with so many
people in Italy I'm getting so many
texts from them praying for you guys and
they give me updates all the time and
it's just the terrible but love to
everybody and around the world
yeah did you see some of the footage
coming from Italy is really beautiful
like people like going out on balconies
and singing oh really it's really
heartwarming yeah the Italians would
sing in at a certain time and
everybody's singing along it was the
trend everybody had good voices
it seems yeah I don't know if we have
the equivalent here in America I was
like I am I am the equivalent of that
with just mic you know the golden voice
God gave me if you want a gold I can now
sing a little opera maybe this will
spread good cheer around the world I
know yeah if you've got some opera for
us that would be lovely
so I'll just hold a note real long and
see if anyone's no one holds a note
better than you you want to hear hear me
really I didn't warm up this morning but
I'll give it to you all right
this is for the world right now all
right three two one
[Music]
oh are you okay nope I have one question
for you Adam why is it that when you're
singing you pose like a monster oh are
you are you playing a lot of guitar
these days yeah I have been playing I
like the last three or four days I'm
like what do I do
oh yeah I'll play guitar yeah let's try
something I like to say it my way which
is there's a line on down the road you
know what I also say I used to think for
years that when Van Morrison said going
down to the old mine with a transistor
radio I used to think he was saying
going down on an old man for a
transistor radio and house like that
must have been some great how old
listening to a lot of music in the house
you too uh no not a lot of music
screening a ton of movies
making my kids watch all the Pink
Panther movies with Peter Sellers
we're gonna watch Young Frankenstein
right yes I couldn't get a cook and I my
thing again I don't know what the hell's
going on and anyways I ended up from
young private side putting on young
Lincoln old Henry Fonda movie you
watching any of your movies with the
kids this is a good time to make them
watch your stuff yes now we've we've
been watching all of my stuff and now
we're ranking it all and you know what
my kids they literally and every one
I've done is incredible so you can't my
niece just had a baby
your niece had a baby that's great
that's fantastic little summer little
summer and a family way to go guys and
thanks to the staff at the hospital the
taking care of everybody and making sure
you know the corona of it all everybody
was nervous about that but everything's
good and healthy and way to go way to go
guys nice new babe we're lucky that we
live at a time when you and I can get on
the computer and talk like this if this
had happened you know whatever 10-15
years ago I'd have to sneak into your
house to come talk to you I know I
wouldn't I get in my legs would be in
the house 20 minutes before I was it'd
come in like snakes you'd see legs
freckled legs coming in for 20 minutes
you'd be like Hornets coming that's a
strong he don't wash their hands like
everybody's saying to do yeah follow the
rules and everyone says the same thing
which is act as if you have the virus so
stay away from people and this too shall
pass so try and remain optimistic
I love you take care of yourself oh yes
everybody loved you out there yeah and
thank you for spreading some good cheer
that's a nice thing see y'all soon all
right we'll see you later bye